hagamos más ejemplos de límites y
resolvamos algunos problemas
digamos que tengo el límite
cuando x tiende a 3
d
digamos que sea x cuadrada
- 6 x + 9
y eso sobre x cuadrado menos 9 lo
primero que me gusta hacer en estos
problemas es insertar el valor y ver si
tiene sentido si ya terminamos habrá que
tener cuidado si la función es continua
y en ese caso ya terminamos pero veamos
si pongo 3 en el numerador es 3 al
cuadrado que es 9 - 18 + 9 eso resulta
en cero y en el denominador es 3 al
cuadrado que es 9 menos 9 también me da
un 0 lo cual lo cual resulta en 0 sobre
0 y eso no nos gusta no nos gusta tener
nada que esté dividido entre 0
definitivamente no nos gusta tener 0
sobre 0 habrá alguna manera de
simplificar esta expresión de manera que
al evaluarla en 3 haga sentido cuando
observo estos dos polinomios y haciendo
una inspección sencilla parecen fáciles
de factorizar es decir factorizar los
reescribir el numerador y el denominador
y con suerte eso me permite simplificar
veamos esto esto parece ser x + 3
no no esto más bien es x
es que parecía x + 3 al cuadrado pero no
es x menos 3 x x
y esto está dividido entre x 3
por equis 3
cierto así que el límite de esta
expresión será el mismo límite de esta
expresión cuando x tiende a 3 no hay
nada que podamos hacer para cambiar el
hecho de que esta función o expresión no
está definida cuando x vale 3 pero si
podemos simplificar la podremos saber
cuál es el valor al que se acerca ahora
si asumimos que x puede tomar cualquier
valor que no sea 3 entonces podremos
suprimir estos términos iguales que
están en el numerador y el denominador y
podríamos decir aunque bueno no estoy
siendo muy riguroso pero esta es una
forma de pensar
que esto es lo mismo que el límite
cuando x tiende a 3 de x 3 entre x 3
y ahora veamos qué es lo que pasa en el
numerador obtenemos 3 menos 30 y en el
denominador 33 que 6 y ahora obtenemos
un 0 dividido entre 16 eso está muy bien
y eso es un cero
y es interesante la primera vez
obtuvimos 0 dividido entre 0 y esta vez
obtenemos 0 por haber simplificado pero
es muy importante no olvidar que estas
expresiones no están definidas cuando x
vale 3 y si hiciéramos la gráfica
observaríamos que a medida que x se va
acercando a 3 el valor de esta expresión
se acerca a 0 y ya sé lo que estás
pensando cada vez que me encuentre una
expresión que tenga 0 dividido entre 0
el valor será 0 cuando lo evalúe bueno
pues vamos a explorarlo pero primero
déjame borrar esto
y ahora hagamos otro ejercicio que sea
el límite cuando x tiende a 1
es que como voy pensando los ejercicios
mientras los voy haciendo que sea de x
cuadrada
- x cuadrada menos x
- 2 este no la verdad mejor que sea más
equis y todo eso que esté dividido entre
x menos uno entonces ahora vamos a
evaluar y resulta que es 1 al cuadrado
más uno menos 12 0 sobre 1 menos 10
así que obtenemos 0 sobre cero así que
tenemos que hacer algo y vamos a
factorizar y esto será lo mismo que
tener el límite
cuando x tiende a 1 d
x menos 1 que está x x 2
y está dividido entre x menos 1 y creo
que estamos descubriendo que el trabajar
con problemas de límites al simplificar
las expresiones es probable que logremos
encontrar un factor en el numerador que
elimine el término en el denominador que
hace a esta expresión indefinida y un
buen punto de inicio será tratar de
simplificar utilizando la expresión que
tenemos en el denominador bueno a veces
tendrás expresiones mucho más
complicadas y más difíciles de
simplificar y así que si asumimos que x
puede tomar cualquier valor menos 1
entonces esta expresión ideal que se
encuentra en el numerador podríamos
cancelarlas
y entonces llegamos a esta expresión que
es el límite cuando extiende a 1 de x +
2 cuando esto está muy fácil cuál es el
límite cuando x tiende a 1 de x + 2 pues
es uno más 2 y es igual a 3 es
interesante si solo intentamos evaluar
las expresiones utilizando los valores
obtenemos 0 dividido entre 0 y en el
ejemplo previo pudimos obtener que el
resultado era 0 pero en este caso
obtenemos como resultado 3 y yo te
quiero invitar a que utilizando una
calculadora gráfica realices las
gráficas y observes qué es lo que está
pasando y entonces observes con
detenimiento cómo a medida que x se
acerca estos valores el límite
corresponde a los valores que obtuvimos
y vamos inventa tus propias expresiones
bueno en realidad eso es lo que yo hago
pero vamos a otro problema ahora vamos
con este que me parece realmente
interesante
digamos que cuál es el límite cuando x
tiende a infinito es infinito x cuando
tiende a infinito de x cuadradas
+ 3
/ este / x que sea / x al cubo
normalmente pienso en estos problemas de
esta manera estas expresiones se
convertirán en valores muy muy muy
grandes lo que me gusta pensar en estos
problemas es qué pasaría cuando tengo
valores muy muy grandes para x por
ejemplo podríamos pensar qué pasa cuando
x toma el valor de un millón o qué pasa
cuando x toma el valor de un billón
podrías utilizar una calculadora
insertar estos valores y observar cuál
es el punto y ahora analicemos cada
término cuál de ellos crecerá con mayor
rapidez por ejemplo será
este que está aquí de x al cubo o x al
cuadrado no es x al cubo el que crecerá
más rápido y obtendrá valores más
grandes y más grandes a medida que x
crezca es decir el denominador crecerá
más rápido que el numerador e iremos
obteniendo cada vez fracciones más
pequeñas y más pequeñas los términos
siguen creciendo y la fracción pequeña
pequeña pequeña y a medida que x se
acerque infinito la fracción se acerca a
0 esta es una manera de abordar el
problema pero también hay otras por
ejemplo podrías intentar dividir esta
expresión y obtendrías algo así como 1
entre x más algunos términos y tal vez
hacer la reflexión sobre el límite de 1
sobre de x cuando x tiende a infinito
también es 0 pero vamos a otro ejemplo
ahora veamos
límite cuando x tiende a infinito d
3x cuadrada más x dividido entre 4 x
cuadrada menos 5 a primera vista estos
problemas parecen complicados pero en
realidad son muy fáciles
algo que teníamos que considerar es que
pasa cuando x toma valores grandes es
decir cómo se comportan cada uno de
nuestros términos y podríamos observar
que estos términos pequeños que se
encuentran aquí en estos casos ya no
cuentan
es decir los otros términos están
creciendo podríamos decir al mismo ritmo
que podemos no tomarlos en cuenta y en
este caso el límite es muy sencillo pues
es 3 dividido entre 4 tenemos que
observar el ritmo al que crece cada uno
de los términos cómo se comportan y
observar hacia dónde se acercan y si
tienen el mismo término podemos
cancelarlo bien esta podría ser una
forma poco rigurosa pero nos lleva a los
resultados nos vemos en el próximo vídeo